hi William come on in William AC is here
crashing you know I apologize for my
curfew smell something I apologize don't
discuss this Jim
Jim got excited right before you came in
and when he gets excited sometimes he a
little gasps sneaks out yeah how are you
sir I love nothing is funnier than a
fart absolutely the last three films
I've done I tried to put in fart jokes
I've failed every time but I haven't
given up what were these films the three
films I directed they all had extensive
fart jokes the joke that somebody cut it
nobody knew who or is the joke of the
place it was done what was the point of
the jolly boys keep going does your wife
think fart jokes are funny not as funny
as I do I think maybe guys share the
love of farts more than the women will
you drop ones I think they're funny but
I'm also a comedian so I'm kind of dead
inside anyway right yeah will you drop
one inappropriate place a gasser what
kind of question is the very course no
one in this room does oh I love it that
has to be even better for you because I
feel I think people have such reverence
for William H Macy the great actor and
then if you're just like farting around
then you're not gonna get blamed no if
we were in an elevator you'd be the last
person I thought it was and you could
just sit there at you she's so pretty
that's disgusting oh my lord
I finally started taking yoga and one of
the first yoga classes I took in Hawaii
I walked in and I thought I'm gonna like
this they were the most beautiful women
there and men right I mean Yoga body
there yeah and we were about four
minutes into it when someone let one go
it's like a b-flat and it was sustained
and it was so loud and no one copped to
it and you know you have to breathe and
yo I was laughing I couldn't breathe
it's very common there I've heard
because of the the way the body's
contorting and like over the stomach and
the stomach muscles that they see people
fart in yoga all the time it's just part
of it yeah they say as you're doing
certain poses are like we're actually
compressing your intestines right now
you allow like they're telling you we're
wringing your insides right now it's not
gonna come out and I'm a golden
retriever I must have been in a previous
light I lie fight i'm gaseous are they
bad usually or are they human are they
[ __ ] repulsive you know my farts
don't sting do you like when people are
bothered by them well I don't mind you
not only does Jim not mine
Jim Norton has been a comedian for some
time now for many years he's got many
specials he's got a lot of credits and I
have never seen him happier than when
somebody is grossed out by his
flatulence ever ever I've never seen you
just let it rip your times yeah
and we loudly everywhere in public all
the Starbucks yeah now you're quiet oh
I'm Lutheran I would never do sneak it
out and blame the devil whenever you're
in a room with William HMAC and he goes
such as mayor's are an evil spirit it's
him yeah it's him were you religious
growing up no not so much a pretty
religious background my grandmother was
very religious my father was pre
ministerial for a while until he just
couldn't do it and interestingly I went
to Sunday school one time and this guy
draw a big circle on the board and he
said this is Earth and this is heaven
and this is purgatory and I said what's
beyond there and he said there's nothing
beyond there and I said well there's got
to be something beyond there and he said
no that's God and I said well but what's
beyond that and he sort of changed the
subject I get home there's my dad he
said what did you say in Sunday school
and I told him the whole story and he
said mm-hmm you don't have to go anymore
Wow Wow was it because you're
questioning it or because he think I
didn't have a good answer for you yeah
that guy was an idiot yeah you are if I
wasn't asked you about it was something
about your about the movie all the film
you do that you got made that you said
you went to the altar a couple of times
with and you and you couldn't get done
why couldn't you it's about someone
going to an AAA meeting who falls in
love with a he's a stripper and rosario
dawson plays why was that film so hard
to get made because films are hard to
get made because if I told you the plot
you would be scrapped
in your head it does it doesn't you know
it's not dumb that I'm dumb right which
was famously sold just on that phrase
and people get really nervous before
they write multiple millions of dollars
in checks they do I feel you honey now I
would imagine now it's it's tougher than
then I think it's been before because
we're kind of in the age of the
blockbuster not just being young to
blockbusters for summer and one for
Christmas and we're good for the year
it's like no we need one every weekend
it's hard to sell an independent film to
it is you know making it easier is that
is that are we at the place now where
digital is is is there enough money in
that to make it actually something we
could say this is a real release yes but
it hasn't happened yet
I don't know what it'll look like but at
some point though the independent film
market will come back because there's a
need for it and meaning people want to
see indie films yeah more than
television or different than television
and different than blockbusters they
love those films but we have to figure
out the platform where the filmmakers
can make some money you know you
mentioned in the statement you said
something at Harvey Weinstein about how
everybody knew and that stuff's got to
stop but but he but the other side which
I thought was very honest word that he
was good for the film industry because
of the work and the things that he
greenlit and that other people wouldn't
have touched so do you think that this
whole scandal what's happening because
if a guy like him is no longer gonna be
making decisions films like that are
gonna suffer no no you won't know I
think it's all really really good I tell
you what turned my head it was about two
or three months ago I heard a couple of
women who had been called in to the
office and it was just to sleep with
them and they said it destroyed their
confidence they walked out of there
thinking that they were worthless that
they didn't have talent and when I heard
that I thought that's more than
despicable that's a crime yeah they
didn't walk out thinking he's allowed I
hate his guts or I hate all men it hurt
them deeply and for that he can't be in
our business no need but I mean do you
do you think that like the guy the idea
that I'm not about that side of him a
little bit the side that greenlit the
type of films that we've seen greenlit
before do you think that aspect of it
will suffer like the films like you're
talking about where that most people
wouldn't touch that he might have
touched do you think it's going to be
harder to get that kind of work
done well short answer is no but the
longer answer is who cares doesn't
matter I mean we don't make another
independent film for a year that doesn't
matter we've got to stop this right now
it's and I think it's the tip of the
iceberg and I think the world would be
better if more women ran it how do you
oh yeah how do you make sure that what's
happening is supposed to be happening
unlike a set like shameless where it is
a sexually charged show where you have a
ton of nudity where you know the
actresses on that show especially Emmy
Rossum is you know naked on half the
episodes like how do you make sure that
those women on your show are still
comfortable it's an excellent question
first of all our business is really a
great business it was five or eight
years ago maybe even ten years ago when
you start a show they called you in for
a little seminar about what constitutes
sexual harassment and as embarrassing
and silly as we all thought they were we
do it every single time so it starts the
conversation and you're not wrong on a
show like shameless interestingly I went
into the writers room because I wrote
one of these episodes a couple of
seasons ago and John Wells sort of told
me this is a rarefied air you can say
anything anything you've got to just
open it up and let it out without
feeling embarrassed by the fact that the
half the rooms women and the other half
are men and they do that and inevitably
someone would say something and everyone
would go oh my god how can you live with
yourself that you even thought that
there's a long pause and then somebody
says but you know what you could do so
you know the answer is we talk about it
we talk about it and there are places
where you let it all go and you let your
demons out and all the disgusting things
you want to say and there are places
where it's completely inappropriate and
the bottom line is it's it's men who use
their power over
either men or but used their power over
men or women and it's wrong and it's a
crime and we got a drum a matter of our
business what would you said like you
want sexual harassment things what would
they say in those things that you wound
up using that the first you thought was
silly don't like made sense oh you know
when I say silly it was silly but we
would they call out scenarios they call
out scenarios and they would ask us is
that legal do you think that's in or
that's out and it gets you thinking
about it I got to say just calling us
into a room saying sexual harassment is
a real thing let's talk about it that
that goes 90% of the way because makes
you think about it because when you're I
think when you're presented some of
those issues in the context of the class
or whatever you want to it's like
obvious right yeah duh you can't do that
and you're like wait a minute I've seen
that happen Yeah right right
totally well that's interesting too
because I feel like the majority of
people who would go into that meeting
are people who already know like yeah of
course you don't do this here but the
people who don't know that already I'm
like would that really stop them though
because in their mind they're still I go
whatever if I'm in the situation when I
want to I feel like those are the type
of people that just would anyway do you
think it does actually stop some stuff
from happening yes I do
yeah also I think there's an important
demarcation point you know there's
there's a difference between boorish
behavior and a crime and it seems to me
if I if I say untoward things to you
embarrassing things to you then I'm a
bore but if I use my position over you
as your employer to try to get you to
have sex with me that's a crime right so
do you have you seen things on the set
over the years like at the time didn't
like it registered as mildly
inappropriate that you look back now and
go yeah that was kind of harassing that
was where that was what he was being way
over the line yeah yeah you know
interestingly the times I remember the
times that I spoke up and said you're an
[ __ ] you shouldn't have said that
but I think the guilt that we all share
is that all these rumors about these
guys who were just found
and wouldn't take no for an answer
everybody knew everybody knew and it was
tolerated and well what responsibility
is there when it is just a rumor right
because because you say because the
people who know should be coming forward
but the people who are aware of the
rumor there's not usually if you're just
aware of that rumor like the louis c.k
stuff we talked about it at length but
like we're aware of this rumor right in
the comedy community but with no names
attached to it and no direct situations
to call from I mean sitting here going
like I don't that's probably not true
because there's no I don't actually have
any evidence you know how a person
attached to it right I don't know I
think this is an an evolving thing and I
think we have to be hip to the fact that
things that were okay and my
grandfather's day are illegal now things
that were okay and my father's day are
will get you fired now we are evolving
and I think our shame is that it took
this long but it was inevitable and it's
healthy and we should learn from it and
go forward when you told the guy he's an
[ __ ] on a set was it for was it a
bullying cuz Jon Bernthal is here and he
was talking about Kevin Spacey how he
felt like he was a bully were you was
the guy doing something sexually
inappropriate or is it just kind of just
being an [ __ ] or was he shocked that
you said something to him yeah I
remember one time in Washington a long
time ago this guy was talking about the
kind of chicks that make good good
girlfriends and stuff like that and I
said yeah you should get a German
Shepherd I think he'd really he almost
put my lights out he said [ __ ] you move
will you just buy yours making what was
it he wanted real submissive obedient I
called him on his [ __ ] I just said
you're a cro-magnon and you know he
didn't like that was he somebody who had
like before that or no no I hardly knew
him ah it's a big mouth that happens we
pee if we forget that on sets you guys
are working very closely together for
hours and hours so you really do get to
know and sometimes you get annoyed by
people right and you just hear these and
you're like I got a enough
just shut up yeah and it's a hit
business I mean the women and men in
this business are really cool and it's
uncomfortable when you're doing a sex
comedy and you're you're you're going as
close to that line as you can anyway
that's your job most of the people in my
business are really cool about this is
under imaginary circumstances and we
know where the line is and do you start
going back because like shameless
started eight years ago I guess right
and and even eight years ago I feel like
it was a different time like this is
kind of a new and even though people had
feelings and everything which is not
acknowledged do you think like early on
like we probably shouldn't have been
doing this or that or did you have this
system that he talked about before
pretty well mapped out from the
beginning well on shameless I'm the old
guy on the ominous Greece as the French
say I think I pronounce that right so
did I felt I felt compelled to set some
sort of a standard there and
interestingly I Unchained was for better
or for worse I'm dropping my knickers
all the time and I had a lot of sex
scenes with a lot of women and from the
very first I took him aside and I said I
know this is embarrassing but I'm number
one on the call sheet you give me a high
sign if there's anything you don't like
I'll do your bidding for you you just
give me a wink Wow and I'll stop
everything until we find out what you
don't like have you gotten in those
scenes I've done like one kissing scene
in my life and I got I was it was
actually with nina hartley i got it was
an independent comedy about it yeah yeah
it was the only time I've kissed a girl
and she'd be you know Christina's open
and sexy and she's like she put my hand
on her brush because you know you want
to like she didn't care but have you
ever gotten physically turned on while
you're doing it no no no and my hats off
to any guy that can there's 12 Teamsters
standing there looking at you you get an
erection with 12 Steve well now I need
an erection I don't mean that far but I
don't mean necessarily like mentally
stimulated the reason I was gonna ask
you is because you're married to an
actress so like knowing that
you might have felt a certain way do you
get jealous if she's done a scene like
that like you like no I know in the
scene you can start thinking oh I see
what you're saying
well my solution to that is I don't
watch I know she's had their scenes and
I just sort of closed my eyes and hum
until the over and I think she does the
same yeah I mean if you're gonna do it
right you sort of got to entertain the
idea you've got to pretend like you're
in love or in lust or something like
that but I find it easy to do and it's
really enjoyable it's sort of taking a
tour of foreign underwear for free
you're getting you get you're getting
away with it you're allowed to so you
know if she's getting away with it a lot
too you know you don't like to see it
but you know you know what it is yeah so
he's so smart I did this film called the
cooler yeah and I was great Oh Lord
there's a bunch of sex and then and I
was bemoaning it because fifty years old
when I did that film and I'm in okay
shape but still and she pulled me aside
before I left and she said I just got to
tell you it sounds like you're preparing
to fail if you're gonna do those scenes
you better jolly well go do them and if
you're not gonna do them you better get
them cut so either get in or get out and
I took her to heart and I met with the
director and we talked him through and I
thought of him as any other scene I
thought what's different at the end of
this sex scene then at the beginning
what transpired why is this moving the
plot forward and in about three of the
scenes Wayne Kramer directed it he said
you're right doesn't move it forward and
he cut him and the others we talked
about what it did so I had something
else to do rather than just running
around trying to hide young will from
the rest of the world if you and if you
enjoy the shameless is on no one Sundays
at 9 o'clock on Showtime season 8 I was
there you young well I thought was a
person if you enjoy so if you enjoy
those scenes for that reason like being
in Boogie Nights
does that make you miserable on some
level because you start relating to that
guy and becoming like you have to bring
up like see
feelings of rejection that you have had
in real life in the past and being like
this does happen to people this could
happen he could be sitting there she
could have an ass in her con right yeah
no I said that three times I said it
correctly about sure twice but Paul
Thomas Anderson decided that there was
some truth in that your wife is being
sodomized and this guy's trying to talk
lights it was such a great project I
just have to get it done yeah I know I'm
not the kind of guy that it's probably a
fault of mine I I don't take stuff home
I I don't become the character I've
always thought that's more mental
illness than X so when I say I enjoy it
it's just in the packet it's a measured
sort of yeah it's a bizarre thing to do
it's a bizarre then how I feel sorry
she'll see how I was brought up how was
Burt Reynolds on that set because you
hear mixed reviews about how he was not
happy he was difficult II didn't like
the script and he was so amazing a
legend is that he didn't like the movie
and he's mad at his agent after he
watched the premiere and then once it
got nominated he was like hey this is a
great movie as far as I know that's all
true I didn't have any problems I made
it joke one time and I thought he's
gonna punch me he doesn't have much of a
sense of humor but yeah I wore that you
think it's pretty true he was talking
about we were talking about some shot
and he said well what did i do on
smoking the band and they said well we
know how that turned out and boy that
was not funny smokey in the business
right yeah Jackie Gleason's the best
comedy performance ever done with Scott
it was great I just I don't know my
mouth sometimes you always [ __ ] with the
Alfa's did you do that when you were
growing up like in high school and stuff
did you did you know fisticuffs were
never my thing so I thought I better be
a razor-sharp wit yeah could I get
killed and so Burt Reynolds kind of
looked at you like what are you yeah and
somebody else spoke quickly
diffused it oh the awkward cover-up yeah
in the punchbowl it happens so I watched
I watched the I've been watching the new
season of shameless and my number one
question for you is what the hell
happened to Liam it's a different kid
right oh yes yeah what happened we he's
the third he the third yeah um well they
for one they kept growing up too fast on
us okay and we missed like a little kid
you know yeah
ultimately this season they wanted to
start giving him stuff to do and before
we just gotten babies who looked great
and we had to hire an actor and I see so
Christian came on board and he's really
good he is it seems the the scenes where
he's in the school without spoiling this
great how old was the other kid well
gosh I guess they were 2 years of 2 or 3
years old
Oh some of them yeah yeah and it was it
was yeah the kid in the last season's he
was he's you never said anything he just
been around forever yeah it just sucks
no if you work with if your scenes like
and lost the guy you know Harold
Perrineau and he had the scenes as well
whenever you have seen to the kid over a
series it's like it's hard cuz the kids
get up grow up so quickly and then you
gotta write the guy out because without
the kid in the scene he looks he's 15
supposed to be agent yeah we're talking
about that with stranger things they
were like stranger things they say has
like a five season arc in front of it
you're like to them right now that hello
yeah kids are gonna be well they shot
Lord of the Rings like that right they
shoot them all at once you could just do
that that haven't gone didn't they
haven't done it with stranger things yet
but they're gonna have to he talked
before about this do you do you think on
stranger things are they sexualizing
them in the press too much for young
people let like in the photo shoots
right said yeah yeah do you do you think
the firemen followed it enough I don't
know I just now when I see the press
come out with them they're like really
over stylized and over made up and just
they look like there's a fine line and I
feel like they they're going into that
Hollywood thing where they look like
small adults yeah instead of like kids
and I don't like that I've got two
daughters I don't like this right we
raised the omen I brilliantly pointed
out that the omen did the same thing is
Damien had on a suit when he was three